lorsqu on peut rappeler que nous avons
et ça ne date pas d'hier
un vrai problème de maîtrise des flux
migratoires dans ce pays c'est tellement
vrai que l'on nous dit qu'on n'aurait
aujourd'hui 300 mille clandestins sur le
territoire français j'ai tendance à
considérer que sa poire est quand même
nettement supérieur à ce chiffre
donc nous avons un problème de maîtrise
de l'immigration nous avons une crise au
moyen-orient et dans certains pays
africains qui fait que beaucoup
effectivement il c'est de venir en
europe certains effectivement au titre
de l'asile politique mais beaucoup
également comme réfugiés économiques
donc nous avons besoin effectivement de
redéfinir une politique et l'idée de
fixer des quotas et que le parlement
fixe des quotas me semble une bonne idée
nous avons également besoin en matière
de demande d'asile d'accélérer les
procédures ce qu'effectivement et ça
fait des années d'ailleurs qu'au sénat
mes collègues dans leurs rapports
budgétaires chaque année pointe
effectivement le manque de moyens d'un
côté des procédures qui sont extrêmement
longues et on aboutit à quoi mais quand
les gens sont déboutés du droit d'asile
ils sont là depuis 18 mois 24 mois ils
sont parfois dans la nature et il n'y a
pas de reconduites effective ou
d'éloignement comme on dit aujourd'hui
donc oui il y a des problèmes à régler
et il faut les régler donc le texte il
ya des points effectivement positif je
pense que tout ce qui va dans le sens du
raccourcissement du traitement des
dossiers est une bonne chose
maintenant il faut que les moyens
suivent parce que on sait que
effectivement les organismes chargés
d'examiner les dossiers sont surchargés
et après il ya la question l'éloignement
et ça c'est extrêmement compliqué ce que
la ligne adoptée par votre parti pendant
les débats on l'a entendu d'un sujet
très ferme n'a pas rendu service
finalement à la majorité parce que d'une
certaine façon en vous livrant une forme
de surenchère à ce que ne fait pas
apparaître le texte du gouvernement
comme justement équilibré où tu es nous
sommes dans l'opposition et nous sommes
là pour poser des questions et les
ministres doivent répondre je fais
allusion à l'incident en séance à
l'assemblée nationale où madame goût
roman scène c'est la triste que je
connais bien centriste s'est tout d'un
coup énervé a piqué une colère parce que
le député lui posait des questions et
qu'il souhaitait savoir si oui
il y aurait des vagues de régularisation
et parlementaires ont le droit de savoir
les français ont le droit de savoir
nous savons par exemple j'ai été surpris
de voir que gérard collomb le découvrait
que beaucoup et ça je chiffrent en
dizaines de milliers de personnes et
souvent des familles sont hébergées à
l'hôtel depuis parfois des mois et même
des années
ils ce sont des cas qui n'ont finalement
jamais été traité des gens qui sont en
situation irrégulière et vous savez
comment les appels on les appelle des
personnes a droit un complet ce qui est
quand même assez étonnant quoi comme si
effectivement on attendait le dernier
papier pour pouvoir régulariser tenant
la situation c'est pas ça c'est qu'on a
des gens qui sont en situation
irrégulière est depuis des mois des
années ce la situation perdure tout ça
n'est pas acceptable il faut
effectivement qu'un modèle l'état
tranche et l'opposition est tout à fait
fondée à poser des questions c'est toi
va arriver au sénat est ce que vous
allez la réécrire pour y intégrer votre
vos propositions et notamment la
révision du droit du sol prônée par
laurent wauquiez
bien évidemment que le sénat se saisira
du texte de l'assemblée nationale et je
ne doute pas que la commission des lois
avec françois noël buffet qui sera une
autre rapporteur à mandera le texte sur
le droit du sol là aussi il faut
regarder les choses telles qu'elles sont
regarder ce qui se passe à mayotte par
exemple est-ce qu'on peut laisser la
situation on est à la maternité de
mayotte c'est la plus grande maternité
d'europe on sait effectivement ce qui se
passe il ya des femmes qui prennent le
bateau au risque d'ailleurs de leur vie
et qui viennent effectivement côté
français pour accoucher avec tout ce qui
en découle derrière il ya des problèmes
aux antilles il ya des problèmes en
guyane mais il ya aussi des problèmes en
france je pense que nous sommes tout à
fait légitime a reposé la question je ne
dis pas que c'est une question simple à
trancher mais en tous les cas il faut
que le débat ait lieu